as podcast has bad words hmm hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn
now while quarantined Ryan and I have
been using this time to do something
special not only did we we finished our
next book which is called love people
use things which will be out early 2021
and I cannot wait for you to read this
book but also each day while quarantined
in our homes Ryan and I have both been
calling up some friends also some
friends of the podcasts and talking to
them for about 10 or 15 minutes just
these short but meaningful conversations
about how they are coping and how some
of them are even thriving during this
pandemic it's a it's a bunch of
different perspectives and we've been
recording these quarantine conversations
which is what we've been calling them
we're recording them with our friends
permission of course and we've been
releasing one a day over on the
minimalist private podcast on patreon
you can listen to all 40 days of
quarantine for free if you're a podcast
supporter over at the minimalists comm
slash support now today I wanted to
share three of these important
conversations with you here on this
podcast episode so even if you're not a
podcast supporter you can still get some
value from these conversations I'll tell
you what I think this pandemic is really
putting things in perspective for many
of us we finally understand that an
economy that's predicated on exponential
growth isn't a healthy economy it's a
vulnerable one
I mean if an economy collapses when
people buy only their essentials then it
was never as strong as we pretended when
it comes to simple living
the most recent minimalist movement
gained popularity online in the
aftermath of the 2008 crash people were
yearning for a solution to their newly
discovered problem of
of debt and overconsumption
unfortunately over the past dozen years
we've once again grown too comfortable
but the enemy isn't only consumerism now
it is decadence and distraction both
material and not amid the panic of the
pandemic I've noticed many people
grappling with the question that Ryan
and I have been attempting to answer
over the last decade what is essential
of course that answer is highly
individual it's different for you than
it is for me than it is for the next
person and too often we can play we can
flate consensual items with both
non-essential items and junk you know in
our free ebook it's called the
minimalist rulebook 16 rules for living
with less Ryan and I we tried to
delineate all three categories essential
items non-essential items and junk with
something we call the no junk rule you
can download that ebook for free over at
the minimalists com a slash rulebook but
let me break down the no junk rule for
you right here on this podcast
everything you own can be placed into
three piles essential non-essential and
junk essentials these are the the few
possessions that that we own that are
necessities that the things we can't
live without food shelter clothes etc
while the specifics change for each
person most of our needs our true needs
are universal now there's a second
category what I would call non
essentials and now people often think of
non-essential as though it's junk
we shouldn't own anything that's
non-essential and I don't think that's
true I I think in an ideal world in fact
most of the things we own would fit in
the non-essential pile these are the
objects we want in our lives because
they add value strictly speaking I don't
need a couch if you're watching this on
video you can see the couch behind me
here
I don't need the couch I could live
without the couch right I don't need the
dining-room table that's in my living
room I don't need the the dresser
in my bedroom but these items enhance
amplify or augment my experience of life
they make a life better now the third
category is junk and sadly most of our
things belong in this pile these are the
artifacts that we like or more
accurately we we think we like but they
don't actually serve a purpose or bring
us joy you know the average American
home contains an overabundance of stuff
more than 300 thousand items in it and
most of it is junk now while all this
this junk it often masquerades as
indispensable it actually gets in the
way of a life that is worth living and
so the key is to get rid of the junk to
make room for everything else now right
now during this this crisis during this
emergency not only must we jettison the
junk but many of us are forced to
temporarily deprive ourselves of non
essentials those things that add value
to our lives during regular times but
aren't necessary during a crisis but if
we can do this if we can discover what
is truly essential in our lives and we
can eventually reintroduce the things
that are non-essential more slowly then
we can get rid of all the junk we can
figure out what is important and what is
it now I hate to complicate matters but
I have to note that essential changes as
we change as well what was essential for
me or for you five years ago may not be
essential now in a crisis what was
essential five days ago may not be
essential now and so we must continually
question adjust and let go this is
especially true today when we
feels like a month and a month feels
like a lifetime with the the current
financial crisis and also a renewed
search for meaning that many of us are
experiencing I think our society will be
coping with some critical realities in
the not-too-distant future many new
norms have been established during this
crisis and others will form in its wake
many of us will attempt to cling to the
past to return to normal but that's like
struggling to hold a a block of ice in
our hands once it melts it's gone now
I've been asked by many people even on
these quarantine conversations when is
this going to to turn around and frankly
I hope it doesn't turning around
presupposes that we return to the past
that we return to a normal quote normal
that wasn't working for most people at
least not in a meaningful way and while
I don't know what the future holds I
hope we emerge from this uncertainty
with a new normal one that is predicated
on intentionality and community rather
than just consumer confidence to get
there we must simplify again we must
clear the clutter to find a path forward
we must find the hope beyond the horizon
I had a quarantine conversation recently
with one of my mentors a man named a
businessman named Karl Widener and he
showed me the Chinese characters for the
word crisis I believe the word is way G
and the two characters they supposedly
signify danger way and G signifies
opportunity so danger and opportunity
and and I think there are arguments
actually among linguists as to whether
or not the the second character G
actually means opportunity but I think
the analogy is still apt a crisis like
the one we have here right in front of
us exists at the intersection
of danger and opportunity and we are
undoubtedly in a crisis a heightened
sense of danger lingers in the ether
right now I think most of us feel it but
opportunity is also in the air
surrounded by danger we have the
opportunity to as my friend Joshua
Becker says use these days to reevaluate
everything maybe we needed this let us
not waste this opportunity to
re-evaluate everything to let go to
start anew the best time to simplify was
during the past decade the second best
time is right now I hope you enjoy the
following three quarantine conversations
I had with Dan Savage talking about sex
and dating apps during a pandemic I'm a
giant fan of his podcast the savage
Lovecast will put a link to it in the
show notes I hope you check out his
podcast as well he gives great advice
relationship advice sex advice etc also
I had a conversation you're about to
hear with my former partner the artist
Colleen McCullough who some of you know
from everything that remains I wrote
about her in there she's talking about
how she and I talked about how she plans
on using art to make sense of a sort of
post coronavirus world how to make sense
of the world right now during this
pandemic and also I had a controversial
conversation this one sparked a lot of
controversy among the people commenting
on patreon the the patreon supporters
who are supporting this I think it may
have been the most controversial
controversial conversation I had this
one was with TK Coleman talking about
freedom you're gonna hear that at the
end of this podcast and you can find 37
other Quarantine conversations and so
many other things over the minimalists
comm slash support all right Joe enjoy
these quarantine conversations I'm
trying to capture some of these
conversations they've been very sort of
casual it's not the typical it's a
podcasting we're all we're all stuck at
home trying to figure out
navigate our way through all of this and
I want to talk to you just about a few
things about about sex since since
that's your wheelhouse okay you know
that there are a estimate there probably
like five different types of people
right now dealing with this there are
single people there are single people
with kids there are couples there are
couples with kids and then there are
sort of there's the other category poly
relationships etc and I think you can
more finely slice the couples category
how so well there are couples who only
being apart made it possible for them to
remain together there are couples where
the marriage is sexless but only one
person is disinterested or not
interested in sex and they've been
fobbing the other person off with a lie
about being too overworked or stressed
out or busy to have any energy for sex
and that question is now being called
yeah the there are couples people keep
saying that on Twitter as if couples
have it made and we see domestic
violence skyrocketing reports right now
so don't assume the couples are you know
banging away at each other and enjoying
all of this Bonus Time
well my wife and I have been taking his
advice and and spending more time on our
knees than on the Internet it's good
advice yes indeed and you know I
actually I would say that the her and I
are thriving especially the weeks where
we don't have our daughter I have a
stepdaughter with my wife and so I'm
actually experiencing both sides of the
the the couples with kids and then
couples without kids as well and I've
noticed a distinct difference and and
you you take for granted a lot of things
that I guess a lot of a lot of things
come to the to the forefront right now
and spending every waking hour with your
kids tends to be quite challenging on on
a relationship absolutely true I think
it's important for all of us to remember
right now that not to compare what we're
all going through to a vacation
but if you remember ever taking an
extended vacation with your partner your
partner and your kids it tends to
highlight everything you love about your
kids and your partner but also at the
same time closely after or mixed in
together everything you can't stand
about your own kids and your own partner
and those moments are you know you have
to when you're in that moment we are
really focused on what drives you up the
wall you have to be a little bit Zen
about it take a deep breath and try to
remind yourself of what you liked about
them I love about them which usually you
know on a vacation was what was going on
10 minutes ago as opposed to what's
going on right now let's talk about what
single people should should be thinking
about right now it's very tempting to
want to hop on your dating apps or or
you find past relationships at this
point but of course with the this this
virus that's out there this seems like
one of the worst things we could do it's
fine to hop on a dating app it's fine to
hop on a hook-up app it's not fine today
to hook up in-person face-to-face you
know we've had some scandals with
people's dirty images or sex messages
being made public against their will and
often people say well you shouldn't have
taken those pictures and what's been
hilarious to watch is public health
department's state public health
departments urging people to hook up on
line to masturbate together via zoom or
perhaps a platform with better security
and you know risk taking those photos
because the risk of taking those photos
is less than the risk of getting out of
getting in a car driving across town
meeting a stranger is not part of your
you know quarantine pod or lock down pod
and that would put you at danger them at
danger anybody else who might encounter
at danger so yeah hooking I'm the like
how the hook-up you never know my
husband and I have any other 25 years
that was a one-night stand 25 years ago
I'm very Pro impulse sex and hookup sex
and I'm also Pro Open relationships and
Pro polyamory but not now
polyamory cancelled for the moment
except on a group chat I have a good
friend of mine who is polyamorous and
this sort of I think destroyed that
relation
ship for him and he and his wife were
both dating other people together and
and I'm not getting ready to talk to him
on one of these calls actually and I
think it brought some sort of
abandonment issues to the forefront I
think I think right now if there is a
partner you mean what's that
the second dairy part yeah yeah they
weren't first priority and obviously
what that exposed is for you know I
don't want to speak you're gonna talk to
him in a minute
but what it might have exposed for those
people is that they were settling for
being the secondary partner when what
they what their heart really wanted was
to be the primary and this just made it
you know to searingly clear that they
weren't to probably never would be the
primary and they had to bolt well let me
ask you this what does it mean to be GGG
in the time of quarantine how is it
different now well do TG stands for good
giving in game which is something like
coined in my column decades ago what
everyone should be good in bed you know
practice those skills giving of you know
pleasure without always an expectation
of an immediate return you want to be an
indulgent lover and uh game up for
anything within reason everyone gets
have their boundaries and limits to be
GGG I think right now just requires
everyone to be very very very patient
with each other you know if you are a
couple that's together and you have a
great and strong sexual connection and
there's a lot of perfectly wonderful
couples out there where the
relationships are romantic friendships
companionate marriages and I think those
are perfectly valid and we shouldn't
look at a relationship and say if it's
sexless it's broken or there's something
wrong we should look at a relationship
and say is everybody happy you know one
if it's sexless and one person is
miserable that's not gonna work but it's
sexless everybody's happy great but to
be GGG right now my god we all need
distractions that's why Netflix is
booming that's why Tiger King exploded
that's why you know we're all online and
hoping that our favorite artists will
release some tracks and work encouraging
movie studios to release films to
streaming platforms so we don't have to
wait for a year to see them or longer
and so now is also the time to distract
yourself with you know as well as you
can in your house without having to go
anywhere without having to
sex shop and buy anything indulge each
other's fantasies and explore if you
have a strong sexual connection lean
into it at this moment there's no better
distraction than a dick in your mouth
I need that on your dress you definitely
say it very immediate about a [ __ ]
you're really not elsewhere at that
moment usually yeah I certainly hope not
I can tell you that my wife and I have
certainly been thriving during this time
and we've definitely sort of leaned into
it so to speak
what would you think that is I don't
know if maybe even have some data that
there's more or less sex happening right
now during during the quarantine between
couples there's some studies going on
right now I would encourage folks to
follow dr. Justin Lee Miller on Twitter
he's a sex researcher and writer and is
incredibly prolific and he's leading a
study out of the Kinsey Institute on how
people are behaving sexually at the
start people predicted there would be
quarantined baby boom in nine months but
what we've seen out of Wuhan and other
cities that were locked down in China
that when the lockdown eased people were
rushing to divorce lawyers and to
dissolve marriages it was a divorce boom
after the lockdown there is research
that shows that something that
predictive of a successful long-term
partnership is time away from each other
is not actually being each other's best
friends letting somebody else play that
role and being able to come together at
the end of the day and have had
different experiences I'm going to talk
about something to share it to be happy
to see each other again and when you
kick that out when you take that out of
a lot of relationships when you remove
that time away from each other some
people are going to emerge from
quarantine not excited to be together at
all even even when they don't be there
all the time in the future so you know
people are into their partners I I bet
my hunch would be they're having a lot
of sex and probably hopefully some more
adventurous sex and they might have had
time for it in the past but people who
don't like their partners man they're
probably not having sex and they're
probably emailing divorce lawyers right
now so maybe this is bringing to the
forefront whatever was going on
underneath and if there's
for a better relationship there maybe
that is being brought to the forefront
or maybe if if things were going to blow
up now is the time that's going to get
back in the fight reckoning you know if
if the relationship was good quarantine
is probably gonna make it better if the
relationship had fissures or fatal flaws
the quarantine is probably going to make
that relationship worse and my heart up
to people who are enduring domestic
violence at a time when it's almost
impossible to flee or get away it's a
it's a growing tragedy yeah it
definitely is and and we often don't
think about that when we're thinking
about couples we're talking about sex
and obviously try and trying to be a bit
late light hearted here but at the same
time we've we've got a lead from
[ __ ] to domestic violence I hope
it's all right it's it's acknowledging
reality speaking of acknowledging
reality what do you recommend the
couples do to maintain their autonomy at
a time like this you know one of the
things that Terry and I have always kind
of joked about is that we're very good
at being alone together you know in the
same room in the same house he'll be
playing a video game or you know texting
with friends and I'll be reading a book
or vice versa
and we're able to you know give each
other some space and time even if we're
you know thrown together in close
physical proximity for a long time and I
think that's a really important skill
some people need to need seem to need
constant engagement from their partner
to constantly be the focus you're just
going to exhaust your partner and
they're going to be anxious to get away
from you if you're constantly needy
learn to dig down inside yourself and
find a place where you can be still and
quiet and disengaged but together I
think that's a great place to end it
then thank you so much thank you so much
yeah you know it's funny I am
I still have so many people ask me about
you because I'd really I wrote about you
and in that book that a lot of people
read yeah
I very much and I mean it's a they
always has a very expansive question
like how is Colleen and I don't I never
know how to answer that so I guess maybe
I could start by asking you like how is
how was how should I respond to that
question or if someone's wondering that
right now and they read everything that
remains well I'll tell you that actually
somebody came through my line once when
I was working at Trader Joe's with your
book like in hand and I was like I'm
Colleen and you really a spoiler alert
no I think I might have answered like
what chapter they were on but I was like
I'm Colleen and they were just like
dazed
you know it was like like I had like a
brush with like Fame or something so so
yeah I mean I guess you could just say
she's well I don't know like I don't
know I think good but yeah it is it is
uh funny that people still ask about me
I didn't ever expect that no neither did
I remember when I when I went out on the
road with that book and like 2014 and we
did 119 cities and and as people had a
chance to read it they were that was
like one of the big questions like after
the events we would do well it was kind
of touching her it was kind of a
cliffhanger just saying the whole book
was was meant to be a cliffhanger but
yeah I mean that they would ask and
sometimes not so kind ways like wait
what happened in that relationship you
really [ __ ] up and oh my god that's
next question but hey the the reason I
wanted to talk to you today was your art
well art but your art in particular it
feels to me like let your collages have
been preemptively cataloguing what's
going on right now for the last twenty
five hundred days yeah yeah and
it's almost as though you were you were
inadvertently predicting a pandemic I
know there's something weird I don't
mean weird in a bad way ever I actually
heard you describe your own art as weird
there's something jarring and and
thought-provoking and sometimes dread
inducing but also like hysteria like the
good kind of like laugh-out-loud
hysteria and in your collages and
sometimes all of that happens in one in
one collage yeah by the way
congratulations you've been doing it for
2,500 days I just saw that on on your
Instagram account yeah well I actually I
mean I I actually did stop and like
October so I got to 2500 in two days and
I can I can talk about what happened
with that like why why I stopped but but
yeah I I did it consecutive I didn't
miss a day for 2500 in two days which is
kind of crazy I did it throughout grad
school which was sort of like the
gauntlet being thrown to like continue
it when you're doing something that also
takes a lot of time and energy but yeah
like I think to me collage is a really
interesting medium because it sort of
picks apart all the stuff in the world
like just all the onslaught of media
that you're constantly seeing and for me
collage is kind of a way to make sense
of it through my hands and so that's
kind of the original intention I set out
to do like ages ago and then it kind of
progressed and like as I I've sort of
progressed and developed like as an
artist yeah I've definitely think that
collage is like a method for just like
gaining psychic abilities like in the
world I'm just kidding I don't know I I
think that it is like you know there's
like kind of on the pulse of things even
when I'm using kind of older images and
vintage magazines there's like a way
that things I see collage just parts fit
together in a way that you are able to
tell a story that is sort of imbued with
this like inherent language that we
constantly see in media or you know
photography
or our selfies or cellphones yeah and so
I guess that that was that's kind of
evolved over the years and over the
course of like the last year as I
finished grad school and continued like
the daily practice I started to sort of
become a little bit disillusioned with
like the creative practice and just like
the like I just started feeling like
consistently overwhelmed by the amount
of media in a way that was new energy
media in particular like I mean I just
all media like social media news it just
it just felt like and like like I've
said him many times like accelerated
Kevin it wasn't like it feels like it
felt like things were just like
accelerating for a long time and I would
you know it wasn't just that I could
like look at my phone once and a day it
was like I noticed myself like picking
it up every few minutes and so it was
like this this kind of like continuous
taking in of media and collage was like
a way of me kind of sorting that out and
giving and giving something back to the
world and I guess I started realizing
just how fatigued I was by it and just
really like the level in which it in
itself became instead of something that
was like that meditative space where I
could use and move my hands it became
this like thing that I was just trying
to fit into this like really busy
schedule and I and I really like had the
urge to pull back and sort of protect
that and it in like not have my
creativity be like a OneNote you know
what I mean like like not just that I am
using like have this one outlet for my
creativity to really try and find new
ways that I could be creative or new
ways that maybe my daily practice could
continue outside of like the public
sphere and so and that was like a really
scary shift are you doing improv still
I'm doing improv like just kind of like
with friends for fun so I don't really
have that outlet as of now the Chicago
scene is like kind of it's great but
it's also kind of intense so so yeah
after I finished grad school I kind of
just wanted a break from things
so yeah I've actually gotten really into
cooking which I've always really loved
cooking but to me that's like something
where it's a different way to use my
creativity and just like trying feels to
me like there's there's a connection
between the the improv and the collages
oh not a direct connection but but
there's there's something there but I
can't really put my finger on it well I
mean both of them you know like the core
principle and improv is yes and and
that's I think like how you build any
collage like is you see something and
you know it's not like you're inherently
like yessing every image you see but
like there's something in a part of an
image that would catch my eye for
whatever reason and I most of the time
couldn't and I still can't articulate it
I think your collages sometimes it's
like this the the yes--and thing but but
maybe the opposite of that sometimes
like the no but like you start with all
this chaos and you're trying to make
sense out of it yeah yeah or as my
therapist would say yes like both or
know both you know what I mean so like
can it be both like can it be yes and no
and yeah so I don't know this Anna
different yeah and I think that like in
in it that can change from one day to
the next or even like one portion of a
collage to the next portion you know the
next sort of area of a composition the
accelerated capitalism thing makes a lot
of sense yeah I think that's that's
really coming to the forefront right now
we're finally learning that an economy
that's predicated on never ending GDP
growth isn't actually a healthy economy
it's it's extremely vulnerable if your
economy collapses when people buy only
what they need as opposed to what what
they all of the the the luxuries and and
extravagances if the if it collapses
when we buy only what we need then it
was never as strong as we pretended it
was and and I think now we're at we're
at a point and so I guess what I'd like
to figure out from you is is
you where do we go from here and how do
you how do you use your art to sort of
comment on that or illuminate that I
mean I think you I think for me as an
artist like it's really important to
cause trouble and and you know and I'll
just say like I I live in Chicago and I
came to Chicago to go to graduate school
to get my masters of fine art I went to
Columbia College Chicago I got a full
scholarship I had every intention and
becoming a professor and helping the
next generation of artists kind of talk
about these issues and think about ways
in which art can change things and once
I got in the system I realized that I I
did did not like I have education for
the arts at all and in fact I would I
I taught a couple undergraduate classes
and realized that in fact that is not at
all the trajectory that I'm headed down
because I think that it's part of the
problem but I do because I because of I
think that the student loan situation
specifically with the arts is quite
predatory right now
and I actually think that that will be
one of the first aspects of higher ed
that collapses and I think that will
happen probably as a result of Cova in
19 I think so too I think I think people
really been exposed to this right now
kids are gonna be home for months and
they're like wait I'm paying $60,000 to
learn via zoom yeah yeah and like and
actually what I ended up doing which I
found myself doing is like my classes
ended up just being like group like I
wouldn't say group therapy but just like
I wanted to like kind of my students to
get them most value out of my courses
they possibly could because I know that
some oh so like so many of them were
paying so much money for them and so it
ended up being much wider scope than
just the topic of teaching but I
couldn't in good conscience like
continue with that career path so for me
one way that I wanted to talk about
these changes is really think about
artists and the way artists work and
then also think about the future of work
in quotation marks and the future of
creative work and to me I began to
investigate artificial intelligence and
the ways in which
right now as artists and really everyone
is kind of we have this amazing access
to the Internet and we can connect and
talk to people all over the world like
when we're sitting in our bedroom but
but then that also means that we're
competing against so many other people
right and we're not only competing in so
many other people but now we're
competing against so many other
algorithms and these algorithms
algorithm is is is has been a theme for
you yeah at least our last few years for
sure yeah totally so I'm so I'm
interested in tech and trying to figure
out ways in which we can harness they
like we can create our own algorithms or
we can better understand the algorithms
of like large multinational corporations
in order to sort of yeah to not only
like amplify our voices but just
basically like have some like somebody
some information at the table that like
that can contribute to the discussion so
it's not just like the limited number of
dudes and a corporate headquarters
somewhere you know so yeah so it's
really a process of sort of talking
about that technology and the potential
of it and using that technology as like
a medium so I saw you go ahead do you
see yourself doing collages about this
pandemic going forward or about the sort
of aftermath of the whole thing yeah I
mean I think that you know one thing
that I'm interested in doing is I've
been using like top trending Google
search result like images so I'll look
and see like what the trending images
for that day are and then use those and
collages so it's a way to sort of like
yeah just to sort of begin to distill or
pick out threads to stuff that's really
contemporary and and talk about what's
happening in the now so yeah I mean I
don't know how anybody who is alive
right now who creates cannot be like
fundamentally affected by what's
happening on like a cellular level but
then also in the way in which they just
anything they put in the world is
fundamentally changed
I think it's a great place to Endon
Colleen I appreciate you yeah of course
thanks for thanks for thinking of me I
appreciate it
I like the laid-back calm composure you
got going on I'm trying man
no no panic over here yeah you know you
know what we said we never look in the
rearview and wish we would have panicked
more man I never heard that before but I
like it well you're welcome to borrow it
is transferable I'm doing that anyway
I'll borrow all your quotes and tweets I
Love You Man I'm trying to figure out
what's going on from a bunch of
different people's perspectives so I
just been reaching out to friends and
and getting their perspectives agreeing
with them on some things disagree on
another is having my mind changed about
some stuff and I wanted to talk to you
about civil liberties I mean we're at a
time where we're like just and I
understand why it now seems like the
perfect time to want to give up our
civil liberties and and and so I mean
obviously we're talking about civil
liberties we're talking about about laws
that are established for the greater
good you know for the the community I
often think of the the first 10
amendments that the Bill of Rights as an
example and I just right before I called
you here I pulled up the the 10
amendments because you know we're
familiar with like the first two as a
society but then we don't ever think
about like or maybe we know about Dave
Chapelle pleading the fifth and on a
skit or something but I was looking at
these the just the first eight
amendments and and I can tell you that
it seems to me that at least five of
them are being totally trampled upon
right now and I just want to get your
take and maybe we can go through a few a
few of those but I want to get your take
on on what this is doing to our civil
liberties in general yeah man well you
know as cliche as it sounds one of the
healthy things about hard times although
we would wish them push them upon no one
is that they they force us to reevaluate
in a new
like the things that we take for granted
and our freedoms are one of those things
you know it's it's interesting because
people are speaking now more than ever
about freedom as this thing that we have
to really fight for but as you and I
have talked about before freedom by its
very nature is the kind of thing that
you have to fight for it's just that
sometimes we're so comfortable that we
forget that we're swimming in such a sea
of luxury that we fail to remember how
precious how fragile how delicate a
thing that freedom is but remember in
order for freedom to truly be free then
it has to be the kind of thing that I
can voluntarily give away what you know
I you know freedom is very similar to
what James cars you know says about play
he says that you know the first rule of
play is that he who must play cannot
play all right if it's not play if
you're forced to do it right and it's
the same thing with freedom like may I I
feel the same way about fun lately yeah
I I think of yeah like a cruise ship to
me sounds miserable because it feels
like fun is a requirement any time
someone like like sort of just you blows
a whistle and says you you must go have
fun right now it feels like a particular
kind of of tyranny in a way and and and
now what you're talking about is is the
us giving up freedoms voluntarily is is
appreciably different from some Overlord
stepping in and saying we're gonna take
these away from you temporarily although
of course history proves out that those
temporary removals of freedom they often
don't end up being temporary
yeah and Josh I would say it's really
always this way because I don't think
anyone wakes up in the morning saying
hmm how can I give away my freedoms this
is why studying history is so important
you know I recently heard someone say
something like the scary thing is not
that you could have a guy like Hitler
with the beliefs that he had the scary
thing is that millions of people could
be manipulated into thinking that he was
the very guy that the country needed at
that time how do
that happen how did that occur uh it
always happens this way it happens when
people are afraid when people feel
vulnerable then and only then our people
tempted to give up their freedom in
exchange for easy answers or in exchange
for promises of security and so I would
contend you know moments like this kind
of force us to evaluate the foundations
upon which this life that we love rest
at all times and it forces us to
appreciate it but here's another angle -
I would say another reason why why these
kinds of discussions and debates are
very healthy for us is they they not
only remind us that freedom is always
the kind of thing that has to be fought
for but they also force us to think
about what it means to fight for freedom
in a way that's bigger than just
debating the people who disagree with us
or shouting at people with different
political views on Twitter because for
so many of us we we believe that
knowledge is power but the only medium
of expression that we have for that
power is shouting at people who disagree
but what can we do to fight for our
freedoms they go beyond just debating
folks who are different from us on the
internet what are the things that we can
do in our everyday lives on an
individual level to defend our freedom
and to enjoy the freedoms that we fight
so hard to protect to me that's one of
the most important questions that isn't
really being discussed in a lot of the
political shouting matches right now
where people are making talking points
and scoring scoring scoring points with
their constituents where do we start I
mean it feels right now that like I was
saying that giving up our freedoms
voluntarily is is the right decision
right now you know we're all sort of
self quarantine but but if I'm looking
at these the just going through some of
these amendments to the Constitution I
look at the First Amendment and what is
the first thing we have there the the
freedom of assembly right and and we're
not allowed to assemble right now now if
I was a conspiracy theorist I would say
well it's a government plot
to keep us from organizing I don't think
it even needs to be that nefarious it
but it is still a right that is being
taken away right now although I I
certainly don't want to assemble I don't
want to have a large crowd of people
Ryan and I cancelled our tour postponed
it until November as as a result because
we want to do the responsible thing but
when someone comes in and says hey
you're not allowed to meet with a group
of people I get a little bit worried
yeah so I I think I think one of the
most dangerous things that's happening
right now is the tendency that so many
of us have to respond to this crisis as
if it means or should mean or must mean
that we have to put our lives on pause
until this stuff gets figured out
because what that does is it strips
humanity of its most vital and powerful
incentive for creative and constructive
action and that is a sense of purpose so
when you take away everyone's jobs you
send everyone home and people feel like
I don't know what I should do it myself
I don't know how to busy myself I don't
know what I can do then people
temporarily have their sense of purpose
suspended and then they're put into a
waiting mode and that leads to greater
anxiety that leads to greater
restlessness and greater insecurity and
uncertainty and when people are in that
state where they are disconnected from
their sense of purpose it's not very
difficult to get them to give away
freedoms in exchange for getting back to
life as normal so I think one of the
first levels at which we can fight for
our freedom and I know it sounds very
indirect in a political but I really
believe in it one of the first levels
where we can fight for our freedom is to
get back grounded in the idea that this
crisis is not a pause button that we
push on life but that it is a new
context within which life must continue
to go on so for instance my wife and I
we've been talking about the Diary of
Anne Frank lately she's reading it and
it was something that you know I engaged
when I when I was in high school she did
as well but she's reading it a second
time now
and one of the interesting things about
about this story or her diary is that
Anne Frank was living with about seven
other people and the backdrop of their
lives was the Holocaust they had to live
every single day knowing that on any day
someone could discover them and that
could be the day that they died and yet
they had everyday things take place like
oh it's someone's birthday it's
someone's birthday today and this could
also be the day we're in the middle of
celebrating that someone discovers that
were here and we die and yet they still
had to find the strength and the resolve
and the wherewithal to light candles on
birthdays in the middle of the Holocaust
and that was the the kind of thing that
kept them alive and that may life
meaningful and that gave them a sense of
purpose and if they can find the
strength to light a candle on someone's
birthday in the middle of the Holocaust
surely we can find the strength and the
creativity to do that same thing in the
middle of our situation and I would say
that's where the power lives I would
encourage anyone to read Victor
Frankel's man's search for meaning which
is again on that same topic but I think
we have to fight for our most
fundamental right which is to live with
a sense of purpose even in the midst of
a crisis and once we get that back and
we wake up every day feeling like my
freedoms actually matter because my
actions make a difference then we'll be
incentivized to fight for our freedom
but if we've been stripped of our
purpose and we don't feel like the
things that we do make a difference or
that we don't have anything to do then
we really don't have any freedom to
fight for anyway so why are we gonna
feel motivated to fight for it or that
we can't do anything we're feeling like
we're forced yeah I mean you're talking
about that that's the that's the fifth
amendment right no person shall be
deprived of life liberty or property
without due process of the law and and
when I when I think about that in a
weird way it feels like many of us are
being deprived of life although what
you're saying is we we don't have to be
yes there are some changes that are
going on right now and we have to adjust
to circumstances but it doesn't mean we
can't live a meaningful life in the
process
you don't have to put things on pause
and in fact I would argue that that is
always the case we're always waiting for
some day to occur but of course some day
is not a day of the week but we we
continue to to wait on it because if I
just put it off till tomorrow well guess
what tomorrow there's always a new
tomorrow and that seems like especially
especially seems like something we're
doing right now where of course the
world the world feels pause but we
ourselves don't have to pause life we
don't deprive ourselves of life yeah and
I want to add one thing to that Kyle I
want to try to make this even more
radical because someone could be
listening to us and thinking okay that's
kind of inspirational that's kind of
motivational IIIi guess I can tolerate a
little bit of fluffiness in times like
this but but I want to make the more
radical claim that this is a mindset
that has that has considerable political
impact so for example one of the things
that you that you and I have talked
about before is how you can't motivate
people to do the right thing by just
appealing to some objective list of do's
and don'ts without any higher point of
reference
people aren't motivated by you saying
you ought to be more responsible
you ought to fight for freedom you ought
to stand up for your rights that doesn't
motivate people what motivates people is
when they have some kind of mission that
makes them come alive right discipline
is not self generated it comes from
having a sense of purpose what makes a
person get up and run every day or
person study every day or a person
practice the piano every day even when
it's boring and inconvenient it's that
they have a vision of life that makes
them feel alive and they're willing to
push through the hard times in order to
fight for this thing that they deeply
believe in so when you have a mission
when you have something that makes you
come alive when you've got a reason to
live and contribute value in your
everyday life it makes you willing to
fight for that so when we try to tell
people fight for your freedom fight for
your freedom the best way that we can
get them to do that is by reconnecting
them with all the little seemingly
meaningless things and
everyday life so I recently would wrote
a post that said if you had something
that you were interested in before the
kovat crisis please don't forget about
those interests if you were really
fascinated by music keep making music
keep making art because by the way when
you look at the totalitarian regimes
throughout history what what did they
fight against when they wanted to take
people's freedoms away you want to know
what they outlawed it they weren't
focused on academic books about politics
they weren't scared of that at all they
outlawed things like jazz bubblegum pop
music blue jeans because they knew that
art and creativity and fun and play
these were the things that gave people a
taste of freedom and once people taste
freedom they will fight like hell before
they let you take it away from them and
what we have to remember is that if we
want to incentivize people to fight like
hell for their freedoms we got to remind
them to keep tasting the freedom keep
enjoying keep enjoying good music keep
enjoying good art keep enjoying good
comedy and good jokes keep enjoying the
things that make your life meaningful
that is politically significant not just
motivationally significant man I think
that's the perfect place to end it
TK thank you so much for us brother all
right before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today let
me just say that if you want more of
these Quarantine conversations you can
find 40 of them over on the minimalist
private podcast that's right you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
and usually our guests we record an
entirely different much longer maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast this week for example Ryan and I
are going to argue actually we're gonna
have a private conversation in which we
argue about whether we should or when we
should reopen the country and find our
new normal and I think we're gonna
disagree on some things but we're also
going to see whether we can find some
common ground that's why I think these
private conversations are so important
there's a Venn diagram and we're gonna
disagree about things that's inevitable
we have different beliefs but we do have
similar values
we try to hone in on those and find
those values so well I'm really looking
forward to having that conversation with
Ryan this week a much longer much more
in-depth conversation and you can listen
to that conversation and hundreds of
hours of previous private podcast
conversations on the minimalist private
podcast it's just 2 bucks and it's the
most honest way for this podcast to earn
an income because we don't believe in
advertisements you know we think
advertisements suck so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create by the way when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast you'll receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app find all the
details and all the good stuff and
including its including an additional
podcast episode every week over at the
minimalists com slash support now enjoy
these voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners hi this is Katie from Glen
Ellyn Illinois
Emily was asking for advice on how not
to get too seduced by new shiny things
and then feeling guilty about buying
them I also have a problem with getting
really excited about new shiny things
and what has really helped me reduce
those impulse purchases is when I see
something new and shiny may mediate
reaction is yes I want to buy this
instead of throwing it in the basket or
shopping cart I will physically carry it
in my hands while I continue to walk
around the store and shop this does two
things number one it helps me understand
the physical bulk this thing will take
up in my life if I buy it it makes the
idea of the true cost of living with
this item much more tangible and number
two by the time I am done walking around
store the initial high of wanting and
then holding this new shiny thing said
one off carrying the item around in the
store essentially tricks my impulse
motivated brain into thinking that I
have purchased this item and the impulse
has been satisfied without having to
actually buy it I have appreciated the
object as much as was possible and then
I moved on remember
you can appreciate something without
having to buy it or own it my name is
Tristan Ryan calling from Melbourne
Florida
Ryan's comment about wanting to talk
about the environment without being
negative resonated with me
I have increasing concerns myself and
I'm changing and adapting and part of me
keeps this to myself so I don't come
across as the software I just do better
on one hand and then on the other hand I
don't like to bring it up because I
don't want to be criticized when my
efforts are less than perfect one of the
easiest and best things that my husband
and I have done to affect change and our
children is to take them to the dump I
know that that's really funny but when
they see and smell and experience the
trash it makes such a huge impact on
them the questions follow have been
really good and it creates an ongoing
conversation that leads to a lot of
different rabbit trails but the virtues
of just eating an apple
rather than having applesauce packet not
leaves the conversation also into
appreciating the mangoes that the
neighbor gave you because they didn't
even have to come in a truck from across
the United States so we've been able to
create these conversations and that's
been a really good thing for our family
to help align with our simple lifestyle
it's the perfect opportunity to explain
why we choose the best things that our
money can buy the fewest amount that we
can or the smallest amount that we can
and why we keep those things and we
don't just constantly change and dispose
of things that have value and I'm
talking about things like couches and
mattresses we try and be intentional
with our purchases it's hard to think
that things being easily disposed of
when you witness the stacks of
mattresses and couches and the birds
pecking at them and you we see that
firsthand
and it makes such a huge impact on me as
an adult but specifically the kids all
right Joe thanks for listening today
real quick four right here right now
here's one thing is going on in a life
of the minimalists while Ryan and I have
been quarantined in our homes we're
answering a lot of your text messages
and you can text us it goes right to my
phone right to Ryan's phone nine three
seven two O two four six five four we
answer as many of those questions as we
can and quite honestly we're answering
almost all of them right now because
we've had some extra time and I've had a
lot of fun because I'm getting some
questions I wouldn't typically get just
through the podcast or even on social
media so you can text those questions to
us you can text pictures of you
simplifying also if you join that text
group what we do is every Monday we send
you a minimal Maxim a Monday morning
minimal Maxim to start your week off
with a little bit of simplicity if you'd
enjoy that nine three seven two oh two
four six five four of course we would
never sell your information we're not
going to send you spam or junk or
advertisements or anything like that we
just want to open up the communication
via text message and we've really been
enjoying that so far you could follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimus and if you want our
show notes and your inbox sign up for
our e-mail list over at the minimalists
comm it's right there at the top just
enter your email address we'll also send
you our simple Sunday emails each week
and for our added value this week let's
listen to a song called obsidian from
mixing colors it's the new album by
Roger Eno and Brian Eno I think it's the
perfect soundtrack for a not so
dystopian future if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all I'll see you next time
and minimus